bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est Science Publique en étant ensemble
pour 90 minutes de débats de reportage
de chroniques et d'analyse 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos invités experts et voici le
sommaire de ceux 19 septembre c'est le
Ministre de la rentrée les Français
approuvent ces premières décisions au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
Gabriel Attal fait pour l'instant un
sans faute Grenelle malgré sa jeunesse
alors oui je suis jeune j'ai 34 ans mais
je veux rappeler qu'on peut avoir 34 ans
et de lourdes responsabilités un
professeur sur trois à moins de 40 ans
et ils ont eux la lourde la très lourde
responsabilité d'instruire nos enfants
les sondages placent désormais Gabriel
Attal parmi les personnalités politiques
préférées des Français jusqu'où peut
mener cette ascension fulgurante en
débat juste après ces titres et puis
pour notre second thème direction la
Chine confrontée à l'une des pires
crises économiques de son histoire tout
a commencé par l'éclatement de la bulle
immobilière il y a deux ans et depuis
les voyants passent au rouge croissants
chômage des jeunes démographies baisse
des exportations la Chine est-elle en
train de se rendormir réponse dans 45
minutes mais d'abord un ministre en
première ligne de l'interdiction des
abayas au harcèlement scolaire la
stratégie de Gabriel Attal décortiquée
par Fabien Ricard
Gabriel Attal aux côtés de Brigitte
Macron le 7 septembre à Poissy ville en
deuil est par le suicide d'un lycéen de
15 ans le ministre de l'éducation
nationale promet un électrochoc dans la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire au
terme d'une rentrée qui aura fait de lui
la star du gouvernement depuis sa prise
de fonction Gabriel Attal occupe le
terrain tout azimut comme ici 24 heures
à peine après sa nomination au chevet
des profs et des familles dont l'école a
été détruite pendant les émeutes il y a
une dizaine d’établissements qui sont
quasi intégralement détruits la verrière
en fait partie tous les élèves auront
une solution de scolarisation pour la
rentrée une rentrée scolaire qui va
permettre à Gabriel Attal de monopoliser
l'espace médiatique en dégainant une
mesure controversée l'interdiction de
l'abaïa à l'école notre école est testée
ces derniers mois nous le savons les
tenues religieuses comme les abayas ont
fait leur apparition dans certains
établissements parfois cette fait même
plusieurs années que c'est le cas la
fermeté de la réponse de l'école est
mise à l'épreuve une position ferme sur
la laïcité comme pour éclipser les
autres problèmes qui minent les colles
critiquent les syndicats en déplacement
à la Réunion fin août Gabriel Attal
tente de les amadouer en vantant la
restauration de l'autorité et la
revalorisation des salaires mais le
ministre peine à faire adhérer les profs
aux nouveaux pactes enseignants
d'Emmanuel Macron qui leur propose
d'assumer des missions supplémentaires
pour l'instant les syndicats sont contre
il y a aussi des enseignants qui vont
souhaiter rejoindre le pacte parce que
la réalité c'est que vous avez des
enseignants qui aujourd'hui font des
heures supplémentaires ils continueront
à le faire en étant mieux payé pour ça
autre raté la promesse de mettre un
enseignant devant chaque classe à la
rentrée n'a pas été tenu par manque
d'effectif des quoique qui n'empêchent
pas Gabriel Attal plus jeune ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la Cinquième
République
d'avoir le vent en poupe dans les
sondages
la stratégie Gabriel Attal on en débat
avec Mathieu sukher bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes essayiste et consultant Yann
chanterelle bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes sénateur socialiste des
Français de l'étranger membres de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication ici au Sénat
Alexandre devecchio bonsoir bienvenue au
chef au Figaro Laetitia cru papas
bonsoir Laetitia éditorialiste politique
bienvenue à vous une question assez
générale pour commencer Mathieu Suquet
est-ce que vous faites de Gabriel Attal
le ministre de la rentrée celui qui
finalement réussi à marquer son
territoire dans le nouveau gouvernement
borne alors ça me semble relativement
incontestable d'autant plus que on ne
l'attendait pas spécialement en tout
état de cause c'était une des rares
surprises du remaniement qui était
intervenu avant l'été un remaniement un
pseudo remaniement ou en tout cas assez
peu de jeux de chaises musicales mais
Gabriel Attal était contre toute attente
sortie du chapeau et donc il y avait
pour lui un vrai enjeu en fait à occuper
une première rentrée en tant que
ministre d'éducation qui se passe bien
alors qu'on sait que les rentrées
scolaires ces dernières années étaient
tout à fait difficile à opérer et par
ailleurs c'est un jeune ministre qui a
déjà une solide expérience ministérielle
depuis 2017 il était porte-parole du
gouvernement il avait déjà réalisé
plutôt un sans faute en tant que
porte-parole du gouvernement au moment
du covid en tout cas le poste était
exposé et il s'en était plutôt bien
sorti ensuite il était à Bercy au compte
public et c'est précisément un poste où
on est en back office on fait de la
politique mais on est quand même
derrière et dans un bureau à Bercy là
c'est la première fois qu'il est exposé
sur le terrain parce que précisément à
la tête d'un ministère qui l'oblige à
sortir de la rue de Grenelle et à ce
stade alors en particulier avec le coût
de la Baya mais on y reviendra
certainement à ce stade en tout cas on
peut dire que il est au centre du du jeu
politique et du jeu médiatique en cette
rentrée il y a une chanter de Kelby dont
vous faites est-ce que vous dites pour
l'instant c'est beaucoup de
communication attendons les résultats
vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit bah en
fait l'impression que ça me donne depuis
sa nomination on dirait un petit peu une
fusion de Blanquer sur le fond et du
sarkozyme sur la forme Sarkozy version
ministre de l'Intérieur de l'époque où
elle a l'air sur le terrain avec une
annonce à chaque fois avec des grands
effets de communication ça me donne cet
effet là qu'est-ce qu'on peut en retenir
de ce genre de méthode c'est que il peut
se fracasser sur le mur de la réalité
parce que la comme ça va un temps quand
on arrive mais quand on regarde parce
que les Français les Françaises qui
regardent c'est l'état de leur école
est-ce que mon enfant a un enseignant ce
qui n'est pas le cas puisque il y a 3000
enseignes 3000 3000 postes non pourvu à
l'heure actuelle donc effectivement vous
dites ça donne l'impression d'une d'une
rentrée réussie non je peux vous dire
pour les Françaises et Français il
considère pas que la rentrée scolaire
est réussie quand leurs enfants n'a pas
d'enseignants à leur poste d'où alors
3000 par rapport à l'ensemble des
collèges et lycées c'est toujours trop
mais c'est pas non plus gigantesque
lui-même quand il est arrivé en poste a
dit qu'il y aurait un enseignant à la
rentrée en oublie ça parce qu'il a fait
justement diversion en mettant d'autres
sujets en avant donc ça au niveau de
l'artifice de communication
effectivement ça fonctionne très bien
nous sommes la preuve ce soir puisqu'il
y a quasiment une émission qui lui est
dédiée
une partie de l'émission qui lui est
dédiée donc ce qui prouve que la
communication fonctionne du moins au
démarrage mais ce qu'il faut ce qui est
intéressant à nous politique moi je suis
dans la commission enseignement comme
vous l'avez dit nous ce qu'on regarde
c'est les actes c'est qu'est-ce qui est
fait qu'est-ce qui va être fait et c'est
sur ça qu'il faut juger et uniquement
sur ça et on y reviendra évidemment
Gabriela est-ce qu'il bénéficie
Alexandre devecchio du contraste avec
son prédécesseur pas très très
certainement effectivement pas peine qui
n'était pas un vrai politique alors que
Emmanuel alors que Gabriel fait la
fusion Gabriel Macron Emmanuel Macron
est un vrai politique un vrai un vrai
communicant donc là il y a un contraste
mais surtout moi je pense
qu'effectivement il fait de la
communication qu'il faudra juger à long
terme et qu'on est loin du redressement
de l'école mais en même temps j'allais
dire et je pense que c'est ça dont il
tire le bénéfice il s'est attaqué une
vraie question politique et pour une
fois il a apporté une réponse franche
justement son prédécesseur avait fait
des duos en même temps sur la Baya
Gabriel Attal communication
a décidé de prendre son risque d'assumer
d'assumer une position politique ferme
même s'il ne fait qu'appliquer une loi
qui était déjà voté je crois que c'est
ce qui lui profite en fait c'est c'est
ce à quoi les Français adhèrent parce
que la communication sur du vide ça
marche jamais là c'est pas tout à fait
sur du vide c'était une décision
importante à prendre sur le fond je
pense que par exemple c'était c'était
très mauvais pour l'école de laisser les
les proviseurs face à eux-mêmes c'est ce
qu'on avait fait d'ailleurs à Creil en
1989 sur la première affaire de Voice
donc il fallait trancher il l'a fait et
là il recommence avec le harcèlement où
il y a quelques chose de très décidé
très faible donc en réalité plus que de
la communication là il fait quand même
de la politique même si le chantier de
l'école est très vaste et se limite pas
à la bailleur donc vous dites il y a
forcément il y aura un chapitre sur ce
thème là mais un petit peu plus tard si
vous le voulez bien dans dans ce débat
parce que il y a une chanter le si on a
décidé d'en faire d'en faire une partie
d'émission c'est aussi parce que il y a
cette ascension dans les dans les études
d'opinion et notamment ce baromètre
politique de nos confrères du magazine
Le Point qui voit Gabriel apparaître en
deuxième position juste après Édouard
Philippe devant Marine Le Pen ensuite
Bruno Le Maire Jordan dardella Martine
Aubry Gérald Darmanin je vais pas faire
toute toute la liste qui est
intéressante c'est la progression
Mathieu souquière 11 points en un mois
ce qui est quand même assez fulguant si
on rentre un peu dans le détail il
progresse ou plutôt à droite avec les
mesures qu'on a entendu oui pour sa
progression relativement fulgurante de
la rentrée effectivement c'est au sein
d'un électorat plutôt âgé et plutôt de
droite ou effectivement quelques signaux
qu'il a envoyé en au moins sa prise de
fonction en rue de Grenelle en fait lui
a valu précisément c'est renforts là
alors c'est clairement quand même la
figure émergente du du quinquennat et un
peu plus d'Emmanuel Macron c'est à dire
que les nouvelles figures qu'on a
identifié comme les piliers en fait de
l'arche gouvernementale sous Emmanuel
Macron ce sont des personnalités qui
étaient présentes antérieurement les
Bruno Le Maire les Gérald Darmanin je
dirais même même Edouard Philippe qui
n'était que maire du Havre qui n'était
que un lieutenant d'Alain Juppé mais
qu'on connaissait quand même précisément
Gabriel Attal et avec en plus son jeune
âge des rares à avoir réellement émergé
réellement existé et surtout un des
rares venant de la gauche alors est-ce
que il vient de la gauche justement y
venir il y a deux il y a deux choses qui
à mon sens le distingue précisément de
tous les autres dont on parle c'est un
le fait qu'il est un des rares
héritiers putatif même s'il est un peu
tôt pour le dire encore mais qui
viennent de la gauche dire que Edouard
Philippe Bono le maire Gérald Darmanin
etc en réalité on voit bien que
l'héritage du macronisme aujourd'hui se
situe plutôt à droite et même nettement
à droite Gabriel est le seul à venir de
la gauche mais à la différence d'un
Clément bon qui le revendique encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup Gabriel Attal tente
de le gommer et c'est à mon avis le
deuxième trait distinctif il est
peut-être celui qui s'apparente le plus
à l'essence même du macronisme et au
moins en même temps c'est à dire que il
est impossible de dire qu'il vient de la
gauche et au contraire de plus en plus
les signaux qu'il envoie
son appartenance à la gauche
il me semble incontestable que et non
son attitude et dans son discours alors
dans son discours par exemple en tant
que ministre de l'Éducation la prise de
décision sur dans la Baya mais je dirais
même le discours sur l'uniforme le
discours sur les devoirs qui passent
avant les droits les discours sur les
savoirs le discours sur les savoirs
fondamentaux toutes ces choses là
précisément des signaux qu'on qu'on
envoie plutôt à l'électorat de droite
alors enseignant par exemple je vais
vous donner la parole à Alexandrine mais
Yann Chanel je reprends la liste des
personnalités finalement je rappelle que
Gabriela taille il a eu sa carte du PS
pendant pendant 10 ans
finalement c'est la personnalité de
gauche la plus populaire en France
aujourd'hui pas vraiment
c'est François Hollande sinon 26 ça fait
quand même depuis 6 ans qu'il est au
gouvernement qui a beaucoup de Français
qui considèrent pas que ce gouvernement
de gauche donc il peut avoir un passé
mais en tout cas il n'appartient pas un
gouvernement de gauche par contre ce que
ça peut montrer les sondages déjà il y a
la notoriété accélérée effectivement il
a été mis en avant et puis il y a aussi
la thématique en elle-même qui à mon
avis est au cœur des préoccupations des
Français c'est à dire que l'éducation
peut-être qui n'est pas suffisamment
dans l'actualité puisqu'on parle
justement souvent de sujets
nos compatriotes c'est un des sujets qui
est primordial et qui est au cœur de
leur préoccupations je pense que c'est
ça que ça montre mais là où il est assez
fort quelque part monsieur Gabriel c'est
quand même une personne je vous dirais
qui ne connaît pas la vraie vie des gens
à la base pas parce qu'il a 34 ans on
peut avoir 34 ans et connaître la vraie
vie des gens parce que lui-même n'est
pas passé déjà par l'enseignement public
il est passé de l'école privée à des
cabinets ministériels puis devenir
ministre on ne peut pas dire que c'est
un parcours d'une personne qui a eu la
même vie que ceux dont moi je viens je
viens d'un quartier populaire j'ai été
dans l'école publique toute ma vie dans
les universités moi je sais ce que c'est
je l'ai vécu lui pour le coup le sait
pas ce qui pourrait démontrer des
artifices de communication une personne
qui est un peu hors-sol et qui ne
connaît pas justement la réalité de ce
que c'est pourquoi parce qu'il y a un
autre sujet qui n'est pas évoqué c'est
celui du financement de l'école privée
ça je ne le vois pas entendre parce que
le sujet de la mixité sociale est
également au cœur des préoccupations de
nos compatriotes que va-t-il faire face
à ça puisque ça 75% de l'argent public
financent les écoles privées
dont lui-même est issu donc d'ailleurs
il avait désamorcé ça je vous
interrompre on va continuer de débat de
là-dessus mais dès sa prise de fonction
je crois que c'était au moment de la de
la passation de pouvoir merci Mathieu
avec papénial il l'avait dit clairement
oui j'ai été à l'école privée
oui j'ai été à l'école privée je n'ai
pas à renier ou à m'excuser pour ce
choix qu'on fait mes parents à l'époque
comme des millions de parents le font
chaque année et je ne crois pas que le
combat doit être de critiquer les
parents qui font ce choix le combat
c'est au contraire de garantir que
l'école toutes les colles peut apporter
aux parents à tous les parents
l'essentiel de ce qu'ils attendent pour
leurs enfants et il est difficile
cette critique qu'on lui fait ce
sparadrap qui lui est collé sur le dos
parce que pour le décoller Thomas c'est
compliqué quand même c'est sa vie bah
oui effectivement c'est pour ça
en l'occurrence j'ai vérifié c'est
l'École alsacienne de Paris sont son
état effectivement c'est un
établissement
dans cet établissement mais c'est un
établissement pour dire plutôt allez
élitiste je vais dire ça je vais dire
est-ce que pour vous c'est forcément un
handicap quand on est ministre de
l'éducation nationale d'abord et puis
ensuite pour une carrière politique pas
nécessairement s'il y a une forme de
cohérence si la semence fait une forme
d'élitisme pour tous
pas une forme d'égalitariste démagogique
comme son prédécesseur moi je pense
qu'il sera jugé sur sur les actes moi je
pense effectivement que c'est quelqu'un
à technocrate à communicant un peu
hors-sol mais c'est les actes qui
comptent à la fin et là ça force est
justement d'avoir identifié
effectivement un sujet dans lequel il y
avait une vraie inquiétude dans la dans
la société le sujet de l'éducation en
général il s'en est emparé et en
particulier le sujet de la de la laïcité
de l'offensive islamiste à l'école et
d'y avoir répondu fermement je pense que
c'est ce qu'attendent
les Français et en réalité au-delà de la
communication ce qui payent ce que
montre le cas Gabriel attaque c'est la
politique et là il est il en a fait en
réalité avec avec des actes en étant
efficace tout de suite donc de l'acte
principal c'est l'interdiction de là-bas
il y a pour l'instant le reste c'est des
c'est des volontés des tout à fait
d'accord je suis pas en train de dire
c'est un peu trop tôt pour pour
juger mais
d'accord mon avis intéressé les Français
il a été capable de prendre une décision
politique
ce que vous faites lui reprocher le son
passage par école privée d'abord il est
pour rien à cet âge là on va pas dire à
ses parents non non je veux absolument
aller dans le public quoi vous voyez ce
que je veux dire et est-ce que forcément
ça le disqualifie d'abord auprès des
enseignants de des établissements
publics et puis peut-être auprès des
Français on est aussi le fruit d'un
parcours quand même pas le négliger
surtout en politique c'est important il
y a une partie incarnation et un
parcours si il va à l'encontre moi je
vous dis on jugera sur les actes moi je
considère justement que l'école privée
qui est financée par l'argent public qui
ne participent pas la mixité sociale en
plus la mixité sociale il y a tout un
tas d'études que je pourrais vous sortir
qui prouve que c'est bon pour tout le
monde c'est bon comme pour les plus
favorisés comme pour les plus démunis de
fait donc en fait même au niveau
pédagogique pour l'ensemble de la
société nous avons besoin de faire
société ensemble d'avoir de la mixité
sociale donc est-ce que des mesures
parce que c'est ça pour moi le sujet qui
compte c'est est-ce qu'il y aura des
mesures là-dessus ce qui va contraindre
les établissements et là effectivement
on pourra lui donner quitus puisqu'il ce
sera quelques contraints les
établissements privés à faire plus de
mixité sociale
le précédent ministre n'a
malheureusement pas fait ça puisqu'on a
mis en place un outil de mesure que
j'invite le ministre justement à
utiliser qui est l'indice de position
sociale l'IPS donc il aurait pu le faire
mais après c'est aussi lui un président
de la République qui ne le souhaitait
pas donc faut voir aussi que Monsieur
Gabriel Attal c'est pas lui qui décide
de tout ici dans ce pays la décision va
surtout sur le sujet de l'éducation même
le président de la République a dit
lui-même c'était un de ces domaines
réservés donc c'est ce qui n'est pas
dans les habitudes en tout cas c'était
pas dans la première définition des
domaines réservatifs
et tous ces ministres exécute donc
Gabriel fait de mousse de la com ne fait
qu'appliquer ce que souhaite le port de
la critique je reste sur la question de
l'avenir politique le lien on va dire
personnel vie personnelle histoire
personnelle pour être plus précis
personnel et notamment là le fait
d'avoir fait tout ce sa scolarité dans
le privé et des saints politique puisque
pour vous ça disqualifie un Gabriel
Attal qui effectivement a d'abord
militer au sein du Parti socialiste
envers est-ce qu'on voilà je pense qu'on
peut avoir le droit de d'avoir été en
école privée de militer au PS et de
garder quelques idées de gauche alors
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez il n'est
assurément pas le seul et mais comme
vous le disiez à l'instant on était on
peut difficilement lui reprocher en fait
d'être passé enfant par l'école privée
on a un choix qui a été fait en réalité
par ses parents sans doute que le choix
de de son prédécesseur précisément
d'avoir placé ses propres enfants à
l'École alsacienne Papen Diagne était
était effectivement un peu plus
critiquable le jour où on devient
ministre de l'éducation nationale il me
semble que François Mitterrand par
exemple avait fait ses études chez les
jésuites et il n'est pas le premier en
réalité ni le dernier à être passé par
de l'enseignement privé et en
l'occurrence c'était même de
l'enseignement religieux non en revanche
ce qui est vrai c'est que l'École
alsacienne dont on parle est situé à
quelques centaines de mètres de ce
plateau et lui-même situé au sous-sol du
Sénat donc dans les plus beaux quartiers
de Paris et c'est effectivement une
école très élitiste alors c'est du coup
un parcours et un profil qui peut
alimenter de procès en déconnexion qu'on
entend déjà extrêmement facilement et
que il y a une chanterelle a fait a fait
à l'instant extrêmement facilement à
aller voilà à l'égarder mais je crois
que c'est c'est en réalité pas un point
majeur c'est pas un point majeur si en
terme d'identité politique Gabriel Attal
arrive à se précisément un profil
convaincant on va y revenir notamment
les marqueurs il y a pas mal de
marqueurs de droite on va passer du
temps là-dessus mais je reste un peu sur
le la question de des personnalités
politiques parce qu'il y a un autre
sondage le confrères de Paris Match qui
est assez intéressant ils ont testé
la popularité de Gabriel Attal et celle
de Gérald Darmanin sont son collègue du
ministère de l'intérieur des deux
personnalités suivantes laquelle
préférez-vous le match est remporté haut
la main par Gabriel Attal 55% oui 28% à
Gérald Darmanin comment vous expliquer
cet écart Alexandre devecchio encore une
fois par la politique je pense que c'est
pas la sympathie propre de Gabriel Attal
par rapport à Gérald Darmanin c'est que
Gabriel Attal a pu prendre une décision
politique quand on a vu quasiment
immédiatement les effets concrets
finalement ça a été appliqué dans les
écoles alors que Gérald dalmanin fait
beaucoup de coups de menton mais on voit
bien que les résultats ne sont pas là
sur tout un tas de domaines on se
souvient de ses mensonges d'abord sur
l'affaire du Stade de France au même au
moment de l'océan Viking quelqu'un qui
est affirme policier une position très
ferme sur l'immigration finalement les
pas capable de retenir les migrants
quand ils arrivent en France donc il y a
beaucoup d'échecs dans le bilan de
Gérald Darmanin Gabriel Attal est tout
neuf il arrive et il a un premier succès
politique sur encore une fois une
question qui à mon avis préoccupait les
Français donc
elle est là à la clé si vous voulez
c'est plutôt rassurant pour la
démocratie c'est que finalement les
Français jugent pas tellement sur
l'étiquette politique des uns et des
autres et sur l'image il est juste sur
les résultats concrets je sais pas si
Gabriel Attal s'attendait à être à ce
point défendu par Alexandre devecchio
sur un sur un plateau de télévision
et après je pense qu'il triangule
habillement pour répondre à la question
est-ce qu'il envoie des signaux à la
droite évidemment il envoie des signaux
à la droite mais je rappelle quand même
que la laïcité la défense d'un certain
féministe l'autorité à l'école ce sont
des vieilles valeurs de gauche donc qui
triangle il parle aussi à une ancienne
gauche qui est républicaine justement
voir nationaliste sur ces questions là
les questions de des valeurs et de
peut-être la colonne vertébrale
politique de de Gabriel Attal parmi ces
priorités
il avait d'ailleurs annoncé ça lors de
sa toute première conférence de presse
il y a la maîtrise du français écoutant
le
a priorité ce sera la maîtrise du
français à travers la lecture et une
pratique considérablement renforcée de
l'écriture à la sortie du CM2 tous les
élèves doivent maîtriser la lecture et
l'écriture pour cela nous allons là
aussi renforcer l'apprentissage des
savoirs fondamentaux tout d'abord les
élèves qui ont du mal avec la lecture à
l'entrée en CM1 bénéficieront d'une
pratique quotidienne renforcée avec
notamment la lecture de texte long pour
leur permettre de maîtriser parfaitement
la lecture au fur et à mesure de l'année
l'autre savoir fondamental sur lequel
nous allons mettre l'accent au court
moyen et l'écriture notamment en CM2 la
nouveauté en CM2 c'est que chaque
semaine les élèves devront produire au
moins un texte écrit alors que ce n'est
pas le cas partout aujourd'hui
la maîtrise des fondamentaux et de
chanterelle est-ce que c'est forcément
un marqueur de droite non pas forcément
mais c'est quelque chose qui est
narlésienne ça revient sans cesse dès
que vous avez un ministre il dit la même
chose il dit toujours que c'est les
fondamentaux et ce qu'on le fait ça et
ce qu'on fait oui quand même on le fait
mais par contre est-ce qu'il faudrait le
faire encore plus oui et ça ça prend des
moyens c'est en ça que je vous dis ce
qui propose là il va pas avoir des
résultats demain en prenant des moyens
tout de suite ça prend du temps à avoir
d'avoir des résultats sur une génération
justement donc d'où le fait qu'on peut
être en décalage entre une communication
parce que tout ce qui communique
finalement c'est pas lui qui en sera
comptable puisque les choses éventuelles
qui mettra en place on le saura
uniquement que dans plusieurs années si
ça a réellement eu des effets tout le
fait que à part agité de la mousse on a
l'impression pour des sujets annexes ou
autres mais si on prend on peut dire
qu'il récupère le travail de d'un
Jean-Michel Blanquer par exemple le
doublement des tout à fait des classes
de CP en indications
c'est quand même pas sur la même ligne
que le
et pour le coup le dédoublement c'est
une bonne chose qu'il faut mettre de
manière beaucoup plus importante
systémique de manière beaucoup plus
importante mais quand on regarde dans
les faits il y a des classes qui ferment
à l'heure actuelle il y a des il y a un
manque d'enseignant
revaloriser l'école les savoirs
fondamentaux
c'est la faute de plusieurs années
justement de d'innaction par rapport à
ça et si on regarde bien c'est aussi les
enseignants moi j'étais en Allemagne il
y a quelques jours les vrais changements
qu'on pourrait faire en Allemagne sont
payés deux fois plus les enseignants
sont payés deux fois plus et au niveau
des contenus parce qu'on nous parle la
droite nous parle il faut revoir les
savoirs fondamentaux toutes ces choses
là mais quand vous regardez l'école en
Allemagne les professeurs sont mieux
payés ils sont moins souvent finalement
en classe que les enseignants français
que beaucoup de conservateurs
considèrent que c'est des feignants qui
ne sont pas suffisamment est-ce que ça
fondamentalement changé pendant le
mandat de François Hollande ça est-ce
que je vous dis en tout cas au niveau du
recrutement des enseignants il y a eu
quand même une part qui a été faite et
qui était très importante de la part de
François Hollande ça c'était pas
négligeable alors après est-ce qu'on
n'est pas allé suffisamment loin ne
serait-ce que par rapport au quartier
populaire ou autre ou effectivement on a
besoin de plus de moyens parce que c'est
là où il y a le plus de difficultés où
il faut mettre le plus ou moins et c'est
là où il faut payer encore plus les
enseignants c'est comme ça qu'il faut
alléger parce que quand vous regardez un
élève français et ça il en parle pas un
élève français versus un élève
d'allemand en Allemagne à 13h c'est fini
au niveau de tout ce qui est justement
savoir fondamentaux parce qu'ils
enchaînent avec la culture avec les
sports qui sont essentiels aussi quand
on est jeune et nous on n'a pas vraiment
de travail de réflexion de fond sur les
rythmes scolaires par rapport aux
sociétés dans laquelle on a entendu vos
arguments là dessus il y a encore plein
de thématiques et à Bordeaux à aborder
merci Yann chanterelle et on va parler
de la Baya même si vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer et je vous propose d'écouter
une autre réaction cette fois-ci du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron qui accompagnait Gabriel Attal
alors c'est peut-être l'inverse il
faudrait dire d'ailleurs lors d'un
déplacement dans un lycée professionnel
du Vaucluse et dans les lycées où les
collèges qui sont les plus sensibles des
personnels spécifiques seront détachés
aux côtés des chefs d'établissement et
des enseignants pour les soutenir et
pourraient engager aussi un dialogue
nécessaire avec les familles et les
élèves mais on ne laissera rien passé à
la rentrée je vais être franc avec vous
on sait qu'il y aura des cas
parce qu'on sait qu'il y aura
les uns par négligence peut-être mais
enfin beaucoup pour essayer de défier le
système républicain nous devons être un
traitable
Matthieu souquier c'est d'abord une
décision d'Emmanuel Macron alors oui
mais donc précisément dans les premières
mesures de Manuel Macron candidat en
parmi les rares mesures qui est
inspirées par la gauche il y avait
précisément le dédoublement des classes
dans dans ces quartiers là et je note
que en cette rentrée Gabriel Attal
venant de la gauche n'est pas
précisément à des sujets qu'il m'est
particulièrement en avance je dis pas
qu'il le cache mais mais il a pas du
tout choisi d'en faire le la mesure
phare de sa rentrée c'est l'interdiction
de là-bas donc c'est quand même un
signal et juste une parenthèse parce que
pour le compte de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès j'avais coordonné un gros travail
un rapport sur le bilan des années
Holland sur l'inventaire du quinquennat
de football sur la partie éducation
nationale si je devais résumer son bilan
un chiffre quand même le nombre de
décrocheurs scolaires étaient passés de
150 000 à 100.000 parce que une priorité
avait été donnée en fait à cette
dimension là en fait et on avait réussi
à faire baisser le nombre de décrocheurs
de 150 à 100000 ce qui n'est quand même
pas rien donc précisément ça dépend
d'une filiation dans laquelle
Gabriel Attal a envie de s'inscrire
j'entends ça pour vous c'est une sorte
de l'heure cette interdiction de la Baïa
qui effectivement a concentré les les
projecteurs médiatique les nôtres y
compris on y a consacré plusieurs
parties de débats un débat enfin bon
vous voyez ce que je veux dire pour
c'est un peu ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure ne pas voir les vraies
difficultés de l'éducation nationale
alors c'est assurément une habilité
politique un qui lui a permis de se
remettre médiatiquement au centre du jeu
alors même que le Président de la
République lui avait tiré le tapis sous
les pieds trois jours auparavant on se
déclarant lui-même ministre de
l'Intérieur ministre de l'éducation
nationale ou à peu près en disant c'est
effectivement du domaine réservé donc
c'était pas si facile que ça de faire
médiatiquement sa rentrée en tant que
ministre d'éducation nationale avec la
Baya et la réussite à se mettre au
centre du jeu médiatique il a réussi à
prendre une mesure à imposer une mesure
qui était en réalité très attendue par
la communauté éducative donc c'est une
façon de se mettre à bon compte et à peu
de frais ont été la communauté éducative
dans la poche et ça compte et ça compte
on sait que précisément Jean-Michel
Blanquer à la fin de ces années passées
rue de Grenelle avait réussi à braquer
le corps social enseignant contre lui à
l'inverse la Penga il y avait une
meilleure relation avec le avec le Coran
saignant donc là avec une mesure la
communauté éducative se rallie derrière
son ministre et puis même l'éducation
dans l'éducation pendant l'opinion dans
sa très grande majorité était favorable
à la mesure sur la Baya et j'ajoute que
par ailleurs l'opposition est elle-même
très divisée voire clivée sur ce sujet
là pour la gauche quoi
on a encore un grand thème à aborder
c'est le thème du harcèlement scolaire
donc on va aller relativement vite si
vous le voulez bien sûr cette question
de la balle je vous entends l'un et
l'autre vient de chanterelle pour pour
commencer bah déjà c'est un art c'est
vrai que les enseignants et les
proviseurs demandaient de la clarté
alors il demandait de la clarté mais il
faut être honnête aussi d'où l'habiliter
de nous communication la note de service
que Monsieur Gabriel Attal a pris le 31
août ne fait que reprendre une
circulation même circulaire circulaire
de Monsieur pas bendiaye en novembre
c'est la même chose la communication en
plus donc il n'y a rien fait de plus
donc c'est en ça que c'est un mirage
communicationnel puisqu'il y a aucune
on a vu des résultats à la rentrée et
montrer les deux on a vu des résultats à
la rentrée
mais et d'ailleurs les résultats ça a
donné quoi 60k 12 millions d'élèves on
peut considérer que considérer
d'importance c'est un leurre comme vous
avez dit tout à l'heure par rapport au
sujet qui intéresse et qui concerne
français les Françaises votre avis
là-dessus
qu'effectivement il y a beaucoup
d'habilités politiques mais bénéficient
je dirais de l'acheter de ces
prédécesseurs et ensuite je considère
qu'il y a beaucoup de sujets dans
l'éducation nationale mais que celui-ci
n'était pas un petit sujet encore une
fois en 89 on s'en est remis au chef
d'établissement les politiques ont
refusé de prendre leur responsabilité on
voit où on en est aujourd'hui avec la
question du voile et de l'offensive
islamiste donc il fallait la prendre
parce qu'il fallait surtout pas laisser
les proviseurs face aux parents face
même aux menaces qui éprouvaient avoir
donc je pense que c'était une décision
importante alors maintenant ça voilà moi
je suis très sceptique sur le bilan qui
pourra avoir sur la suite parce que
c'était la décision pas la difficile à
prendre effectivement mais encore une
fois c'est prédécesseur avait été lâche
et finalement quelqu'un qui prend une
décision claire et nette et bah ça
tranche par rapport au personnel
politique actuel et d'ailleurs par
rapport aux personnels politiques
macronistes qui est plutôt dans la
gestion et plutôt dans le en même temps
habituellement allez on va parler comme
promis du dossier du harcèlement vous le
savez ce weekend le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a réagi au
courrier envoyé par le rectorat de
Versailles aux parents de du jeu de
Nicolas qui avait fait plusieurs
signalements qui avaient écrit au lycée
professionnel ou leur fils était
scolarisé avant son suicide c'est BFM TV
qui a rendu public une réponse qu'on
peut qualifier en tout cas en partie de
menaçante du rectorat a envoyé à la
famille de Nicolas selon vous Laetitia
la communication de Gabriel Attal sur
cette sur ce dossier et réussi oui je
vais même aller plus loin je vais oser
aller plus loin je vais vous dire que
c'est une communication type qui devrait
être affichée dans tous les ministères
en cas de crise parce que ce qu'il a
fait c'est quasiment parfait déjà en
termes de timing
bien réagi très vite Gabriel Attal
quelques heures après que BFM TV ait
révélé la teneur de ce courrier du
rectorat de Versailles samedi après-midi
Gabriel Attal sort de son ministère
prend la parole et il a quand même
participé aussi la veille ça il faut pas
l'oublier ce n'est qu'une image parce
qu'il a pas communiqué mais la veille il
était aux obsèques du jeune Nicolas donc
le lendemain il sort de son ministère il
fait cette déclaration précise sans
concession il déclare que le courrier du
rectorat de Versailles qui menace les
parents de poursuit en cas de
diffamation en disant attention c'est
puni aussi vous risquez une amende il
dit ce courrier est une honte
le mot est lâcher le mot est fort et
dans la même phrase il dit aussi que le
lendemain du suicide du jeune Nicolas il
a lancé une enquête administrative qu'il
va en avoir les résultats et qu'il
prendra toutes les mesures qu'il faut
prendre voir les sanctions donc vous
voyez bien que le message là a été
travaillé et a été minimum si on se
concentre sur les mots c'est la dureté
c'est le mot choisi la dureté du message
qui est la clé de cette communication
oui c'est surtout la précision et le
parti pris du ministre kinésite pas à
rappeler à l'ordre aussi
des recteurs le rectorat il les a reçu
les réacteurs et les a reçu hier donc
Gabriel Attal pour une fois est au
diapason de l'opinion publique c'est
bien de d'être au diapason de la
communauté enseignante on le sait que
c'est important on sait qu'il faut quand
on est ministre de l'éducation nationale
ne pas être contre le mammouth sinon
c'est impossible mais c'est bien aussi
de savoir parler aux Français et quand
il prend la parole on est vraiment
encore dans l'émotion déclencher par par
les révélations de BFM TV et sur un
sujet qui est ultra concernant qui
touche la vie privée des Français donc
le ministre fait qu'au finalement à
l'opinion publique et démontre qu'il est
qu'il n'est pas comme souvent ce qui est
reproché vous l'avez fait à l'instant il
n'est pas déconnecté de la réalité il
parle de la vie il parle de la mort et
il parle des sanctions qu'il va falloir
et si on compare à la communication de
son prédécesseur sur ces questions de
harcèlement écoutez le harcèlement
scolaire c'était un des chantiers de
papa Ndiaye je mets au défi quiconque
d'aller dans la rue demander aux
Français si il savait que papa Ndiaye
était à la tête de ce chantier on n'a
jamais entendu ce ministre parler dans
ces mots aussi clair avec une position
aussi précise de du harcèlement scolaire
alors le mot honte qui a préparé cette
communication
qui a préparé alors selon mes sources
c'est Gabriel Attal lui-même voilà qui a
choisi ce mot honte pourquoi c'est
réussi parce qu'il a été repris par
d'autres ministres c'est pas évident ça
Thomas vous savez quand même ministre
sans rameau parfois bon on n'a pas envie
de reprendre Olivier rang porte parole
du gouvernement a repris le mot
la première ministre est encore un petit
peu timide puisqu'elle a dit que c'était
choquant uniquement mais on peut
imaginer aussi je vous l'avais dit il y
a 15 jours et on la redit aussi ici que
c'est bien sûr Emmanuel Macron et
l'Elysée qui certainement a été
partenaire ou de moins commanditaire de
cette communication on sait qu'Emmanuel
Macron c'est maintenant un petit domaine
réservé l'école et que Brigitte Macron a
des faits du harcèlement scolaire un des
chantiers prioritaires est-ce que ce mot
ont aussi fort soit-il suffit et non
c'est là où je vais être contre vous
monsieur ce n'est pas uniquement de la
communication pourquoi parce qu'il y a
des actes Thomas et c'est pour ça que
c'est réussi cette communication alors
déjà bien sûr il l'a dit il y aura des
sanctions il faudra voir si
l'instanction sont bien administrées et
acquis et puis hier je vous l'avais dit
la réuni tous les réacteurs les rectrice
il y aura d'ici le 25 septembre ça va
être très rapide un grand plan de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire qui va
être mis en place donc c'est une bonne
communication politique parce qu'il y a
une
rapide un terme clair un parti pris un
certain courage politique et surtout
encore une fois il répond à une attente
des Français et il est au diapason de
l'opinion publique en politique c'est
capital alors on va parler du justement
de ce plan de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire c'est le thème de
la chronique d'Audet qui va nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
bonsoir Audrey bienvenue à vous Gabriel
Attal qui change de méthode il prépare
un texte en associant cette fois-ci les
parlementaires c'est ça oui d'autant que
le Sénat avait planché sur le sujet
c'était en 2021 au travers d'une mission
d'information qui avait rendu un rapport
fait des propositions concrètes restées
il faut dire l'être morte jusqu'à
présent cette fois le ministre a décidé
d'associer l'Assemblée et le Sénat à sa
réflexion à ses propositions la
rapporteur de la mission d'information
Colette mélo était d'ailleurs reçu cet
après-midi au ministère on est allé la
retrouver à l'issue pour avoir ses
impressions elle était plutôt satisfaite
écouter
ce que veut faire le ministre et
vraiment
issu
des deux rapports parlementaires
celui de Erwan Malan et le mien donc il
a vraiment pris en compte toutes les
observations que nous avions faites et
il va faire donc des annonces après
réflexion
le 25 de ce mois qu'on connaît les
pistes que Gabriela a prévu de
privilégier de garder oui ça concerne
notamment les
numéros ports du Sénat avaient montré
qu'il n'était pas assez connus alors je
vais me permettre de les remettre à
l'écran c'est le 30 18 et le 30/20 ça va
bientôt s'afficher voilà 30 18 et 30 20
il avait déjà été demandé au ministre de
l'Éducation précédente Pape Ndiaye de
les mettre en avant sur les espaces
numériques de travail mais les choses
tardaient Gabriel Atta la promis de s'en
emparer se pose aussi la question
d'avoir un seul numéro ce serait
peut-être plus simple que deux ça a été
soulevé par la sénatrice lors de son
échange avec le ministre ça va prendre
un peu de temps parce que c'est du deux
numéros répondent à des marchés publics
mais la rencontre reste plutôt positive
pour connaître meslo en fait ce qui
semble coincés pour certains de ses
collègues c'est l'annonce d'un grand
audit par le ministre pour recenser les
cas de harcèlement qui ont eu lieu l'an
dernier puisque d'après ces sénateurs un
peu plus critiques le constat a déjà été
fait dans la mission d'information et en
fait on perd du temps et pour eux s'il y
a une question c'est surtout les moyens
à louer
il y a pas de lutte contre les violences
sans moyens c'est bien de faire un audit
c'est bien de mettre en oeuvre des cours
d'empathie il faut des budgets pour ça
et donc moi j'espère qu'il y aura
évidemment des mesures mais surtout
qu'est-ce qu'on budgetées et que les
budgets seront à la hauteur du problème
parce que décréter que on va mettre en
place à sa quand on n'a pas les moyens à
louer pour le faire on est dans une
situation en France on n'a pas assez
d'enseignant on a des classes où il y a
pas d'enseignants comment voulez-vous
lutter contre le harcèlement scolaire
quand vous n'avez pas le minimum de
moyens pour faire que l'école fonctionne
bien
des moyens Gabriel Attal en a promis ce
sera annoncé donc vous l'avez dit le 25
septembre merci beaucoup Audrey Yan
chanterelle je me tourne vers vous sur
cette question effectivement des moyens
on a du mal aujourd'hui à recruter des
professeurs comment on va faire pour
recruter les personnes qui vont pouvoir
permettre de mieux lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire il faut
effectivement recruter il faut aussi les
former à ça et il y a une autre
problématique parce que il faut plus de
présence d'adultes en général dans les
établissements scolaires je vous dis ça
parce que il y a aussi un gros problème
de déficit de médecins scolaire 1/2 qui
on n'a pas pu justement combler des
postes donc ça c'est une vraie
problématique aussi c'est la présence
d'assistante sociale ça on en a très peu
donc c'est vraiment quand on dit des
moyens importants à déployer c'est
vraiment en termes humains pour pouvoir
justement aider programmes en fait il y
a pas besoin d'en inventer des nouveaux
il en existe déjà un s'appelle le
programme phare qui n'est pas déployé à
l'heure actuelle dans tous les
établissements je peux vous le dire
c'est une des critiques aussi du rapport
qui a été cité donc déjà plutôt que de
lancer toujours des nouveaux programmes
faites en sorte que celui qui a été mis
en place ce déploie un peu partout parce
que nous interrompre l'audit que que
veut faire Gabriel Attal pour recenser
les cas de harcèlement finalement on se
rend compte avec voilà le drame de
Nicolas la réaction du rectorat de
Versailles que le travail est peut-être
pas correctement fait là-dessus donc
c'est est-ce que c'est pour vous une
bonne idée de faire cette audit ou
est-ce que c'est du temps de perdu je
pense ça a du temps de perdu ça déjà été
fait c'est pour ça que parlementaire
faut pas qu'ils servent à rien on a fait
un travail il y a des rapports toutes
les informations et ce contenu qui qui
puisse le regarder et qu'il en fasse
écho parce qu'on a une vraie
problématique par rapport au cas de
harcèlement il y a des établissements
qui souhaitent pas le mettre en avant
parce que ça peut toucher à la
réputation des établissements on se
souvient d'une absolument du hashtag il
y a certains établissements ou des
associations qui sont spécialisées dans
l'accompagnement par rapport à la lutte
contre l'arcement ne sont pas autorisés
par les chefs d'établissement de venir
parce qu'il leur disent il y a aucun
problème bah le but c'est justement
qu'il en est pas donc laissez-les
rentrer pour justement prévenir ce type
de situation parce qu'on est face à un
problème que moi-même ma génération n'a
pas connu c'est que désormais il y a les
réseaux sociaux c'est que le harcèlement
malheureusement il n'est pas qu'à
l'école mais oui il continue se perpét
pouvait s'arrêter à la porte de l'école
aujourd'hui donc il y a des choses aussi
à regarder et ne concerne pas que
l'enceinte scolaire concerne aussi
également les réseaux sociaux et ça il
faut effectivement y mettre les moyens
et trouver le moyen justement
d'intervenir
on attend le 25 le 25 septembre
Alexandre avec sur ce point particulier
est-ce que c'est pas ce sera pas le
premier moment de vérité
pour Gabriel vous a dit qu'il y en a eu
un avec la Baya très bien on en a
débattu sur cette question du
harcèlement parce que là aussi on
parlait des attentes des parents
d'élèves il y a une il y a une demande
d'électrochoc qui est quand même très
forte bien sûr qu'il faudra des
résultats mais là où il marque un point
c'est encore dans la communication mais
parfois le fait même de communiquer
c'est de l'action c'est que son
prédécesseur avait dit finalement on a
un plan il faut le suivre ça se passe
pas si mal que ça
il a répondu je crois à une demande de
l'opinion qui était celle de secouer son
administration et peut-être même
d'ailleurs une demande du du corps
enseignant je pense pas qu'il est braqué
le corps enseignant parce que là il s'en
est pris plus tôt à l'administration et
à la culture du palvain qui est celle de
de l'éducation nationale donc je crois
que c'est des il a déjà agi en partie
maintenant sur l'autoroute il faudra il
faudra des résultats mais la direction
est beaucoup plus claire qu'elle était
jusqu'ici mais Matthieu Souquet bon
voilà on le sait c'est pas le ministère
le plus facile enfin pas le
l'administration la plus facile à faire
bouger l'éducation nationale donc est-ce
que ce qui fait par exemple la quantique
convoque les réacteurs certains étaient
présents physiquement d'autres étaient
en visioconférence les retours qu'on a
eu évidemment plutôt en off c'était que
certains ils étaient satisfait d'autres
avaient le sentiment d'être montré du
doigt de servir de bouclier mystère
est-ce que c'est pas un premier accro
dans sa relation avec le corps
enseignant comment vous l'analysez je
sais pas permettez-moi de faire juste un
tout petit pas de côté sur cette
question du harcèlement scolaire il y a
effectivement la façon dont
l'institution elle-même attrape le sujet
et traite le sujet mais c'est aussi
l'occasion quand même de poser à
l'ensemble de la société à l'ensemble de
la société civile la question de la
violence à l'école et la question de la
violence dans la société et en
l'occurrence n'ont pas de la violence
sur les jeunes mais de la violence entre
jaune et pour le coup c'est un phénomène
plutôt émergent alors amplifié par les
réseaux sociaux mais c'est précisément
un sujet dont l'ensemble de la société
en fait devrait se saisir et pas
seulement en injonction faite à
l'institution scolaire parce que
précisément ça regarde tout le monde que
évidemment les parents ont un rôle à
jouer évidemment les gamins ont un rôle
à jouer alors l'école évolue et l'école
progresse sur ces sujets là je suis
qu'une époque où les châtiments
corporels ça existait à l'école et puis
la société a dit stop et l'institution
elle-même a dû évoluer il fut un temps
plus récent encore ou le bizutage ça
existait et donc c'était déjà de la
violence entre jeunes donc on progresse
sur ces sujets là mais on voit bien que
avec le harcèlement scolaire et
l'amplification des réseaux sociaux on
est sur un phénomène de société nouveau
et problématique alors que l'école est
normalement un sanctuaire c'est fait
bien longtemps qu'elle n'est plus c'est
intéressant parce que justement je crois
que c'était la communication de papel il
avait dit nous avons échoué
collectivement comme si c'était la
responsabilité de la société donc je
vous rejoins évidemment qu'il y a une
responsabilité de la société mais je
crois que l'attente des parents c'était
justement que l'institution s'empare du
sujet on avait quand même l'impression
que le les réacteurs l'administration
refusaient finalement voulait mettre la
poussière sous le tapis et là où Gabriel
Attal marque un point c'est qu'il oblige
l'institution à se saisir du sujet et de
ce point de là je crois qu'il y a un
progrès merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat qui
était passionnant je vous dis à très
bientôt sur public c'est